Everybody agrees that paragliding is a mental game.
You ask anyone? Oh yes, it's a mental game,
everything is in your head, etcetera.
But how many pilots do you really know that truly embrace
this mental journey that truly trained their mind in the same
way as we train ground handling or thermally?
So everything that I pointed out and everything that I wanted to
happen did happen. I went a few days Volvic in
Bolivia without much plan. I didn't even download it all
the maps for this Volvic because I'd never thought that I would
go so far. So it was a real kind of real
venturing, kind of like landed somewhere now to planet 4/6.
At some point I was like, I really don't know where I am.
So there's no network, no maps. So it's just follow the montage
I broke. I think the whole conversation
can be summarized as like, be honest with yourself and truly
honest how uncomfortable it may be and whatever comes out of it,
just follow it and you can't go wrong.
Totally get it. And and that's why I was so
fascinated when when when we brought out the topic of
honesty, because. This is one of the questions
that I always ask my pilots. Where What's the ultimate goal?
Where do you imagine yourself as a pilot in years?
What type of? Pilot, do you want to become?
What truly triggers you for flying?
If you can't fail and the sky is the limit, where would you like
to take your flying? And it's always interesting
because the answers before we were mostly comparing ourselves
to to our village, our neighbours, our Co workers.
This is why the choice of your job and work environment is so
important, because it will define what you're focusing on
naturally. You can't really avoid it, but
now. Ladies and gentlemen, boys and
girls, and everyone along with them.
Welcome back to Paragliding Apples.
It's that time of the week when we bring you more awesomeness
related to all things paragliding.
And in case you're new here, I'm your host Aninder Singh.
And in case you haven't done so already, do consider smashing
that like and subscribe button or dropping in a rating wherever
possible. These small acts of kindness
helps us bring these unfiltered and honest conversations to many
more pilots out there and ultimately making the skies a
more safer and more enjoyable. Place to be.
Now for today's episode, I'll just be honest, you know,
because I found it super hard to put together an intro for this
one, and I'll tell you the reason why.
Firstly, because we live in a world where the way we interact
with our very own emotions is changing at a rapid pace.
If you look at the past decade or so, we have gotten so used to
feeding our brains with endless stimuli, spiking our dopamine
levels to a point where that kind of way of thinking is
becoming the new normal. And this very shift has led many
of us to present a facade of invulnerability on the outside.
But deep down, as humans with our primitive brains, we all
struggle to keep up with the digital age and the ever
shortening attention spans. I'm sure you can agree that we
are often at odds with the very foundation of way humans
interact and connect with each other.
And I completely understand that this might sound a bit too
philosophical to begin with, but I cannot help but think about
how relationships today, be it interpersonal, be it financial
or otherwise, are simply becoming more challenging than
ever. And many of us, me included,
find it hard to strike the little balance between such
aspects of life. Where we have emotions like self
doubt and other areas of life along with them, such as
unfiltered honesty is something that we all can strive to
improve upon. So in today's episode, we are
exploring a first of its kind of a topic, which is based on the
Wellness wheel section of this podcast.
And that is how to build a healthy relationship with flying
in your life. And I completely understand that
it's a massively vast subject and there's no one way to cover
all aspects of it in a single episode.
But this is our small attempt here at Paragliding Atlas,
featuring someone who has visualised their dreams, worked
tirelessly to realise them, and found a way to strike a
rewarding balance in this sport. So without further ado, if
you're seeking inspiration, clarity or just a fresh
perspective on how to make flying more fun, this one's
coming to you straight from Paragliding Atlas Studios,
featuring Kinga Mastalis, a one-of-a-kind pilot who truly
embodies the spirit of what we also stand for in here at
Paragliding Atlas. And that is to dream, believe
and achieve. So, TuneIn, and I hope you like
it. Dingo Marsalis, thank you so
much for joining us on Paragliding Atlas.
It's an absolute honour to have you on the show.
How is life treating you in New Zealand today?
Oh amazing. New Zealand is always an amazing
place to be in. Southern Alps is one of the most
beautiful mountain playgrounds in the world.
It's always nice to be here. We are in the middle of summer,
long days, good flying so nothing to complain about.
I can imagine I am on the complete opposite side of the
globe, 12 hours of time difference.
But I'm just curious because when it comes to winter
destinations we often hear about the cross country paradises in
South America and other places. Why does New Zealand or
Australia for that matter not become that popular?
Is it just the geographical location or is it just the
flying conditions like Scandinavia only appear once in
a while and not that consistent over a period of time?
So there's a few reasons that Colombia or Mexico have become
very popular destinations because of the American
population goes there and advertises it to the world.
It's very close to them while and also and also the flying
there, it's a little bit more straightforward and consistent.
In New Zealand we have two islands on the north who has
rolling hills and beautiful coast.
The South Island is basically Southern Alps going going across
from more than 1000 kilometers. So it's a particular environment
because we are on an island surrounded by a lot of water,
Tasman Sea on one side and Pacific on the other.
And because of this, flying here, it's a little bit more
complex than many other places. Doesn't necessarily mean that
it's less consistent than for example, flying in the Alps, but
definitely requires a little bit more understanding and and
thinking about what's happening with the weather.
Because of this proximity of the ocean to the weather contained
pretty quickly. The wind systems are way more
complex because we don't only have usual meteorological wind
and valley winds coming through the valleys and terming days,
but also we have two sea breezes coming from West from Tasman Sea
and from the east from Pacific. And really depending on the day
and depending what's happening in a bigger picture in the
ocean, what's low, high systems develop and then on the Tasman
Sea and anything, anything like this, we we may have very
different conditions. This can be hard to grasp if you
come here for a week or two as an intermediate pilot.
So definitely, for example, Columbia will be probably the
safer choice for a 50 hour pilot who just wants as much airtime
as possible within the week of their holidays.
But at the same time, when it comes to adventure and the
beauty of the mountains and the wilderness and very interesting,
breathtaking flying. New Zealand is.
Really hard to beat. So it's not better or worse,
just very different. And of course New Zealand is far
away from everything. The tickets are more expensive.
It's quite a journey. If you come from Europe, you
have 12 hours of time difference.
It doesn't make much sense to come for a week.
You will just get over your jet lag and then it's time to come
back. It is more committing when it
comes to logistics, but it's not worth it.
And there are reasons why I chose it from my home and why I
keep coming back here every year for last decade.
I, I just love the way you explained it.
I was mesmerizing hearing you talk about the beauty of that
housing kilometer mountain range.
I was just checking out your Instagram and I was like wow, I
thought those kind of landscapes were only existing in
Scandinavia or in the Himalayas. But uh, housing kilometers of an
endless playground if you know how to navigate seems like an
adventure. I can totally understand why you
are choosing to be a part. Of it definitely is and so we
can talk about it more later. But what I would add here is
also that Southern Alps here in New Zealand have have no roads.
Basically there's very few roads.
So adventure flying Volbevac mode flying is a natural way of
going through and I fly with my Volbevac kit here for the whole
season, even if I don't necessarily plan to go BV.
If I want to fly through Backcountry, it's a good day.
I want to fly into the mountains.
It makes sense to take some basic BB kit with you because
other if you land somewhere, sometimes the best decision is
to to land high on the slope and spend the night and fly out on
next day. Because the depending where you
are, walking out through the valley can be very long and slow
process. Some of the valleys don't even
have a trails, not to mention roads.
But the same time we basically have no trace.
So if it's not a glacier or vertical rock, you can top plant
virtual anywhere and everywhere. And this makes it a really fun
playground when the like you, you just fly.
This month is a little bit differently than let's say
European Alps, where every time you land in the valley there is
a road, hotel, bus stop, railway, whatever.
But this being said, you have to be very careful.
We're landing because there was power lines and houses and
limited. It's relatively easy to slow
plant somewhere happily because there's plenty of space.
You don't have to be precise in it, but then getting out maybe a
whole other adventure. I love the anecdote that you had
at the end. What I was curious is how's the
wildlife scenario if you get stuck out in the wilderness for
a couple of days? So how much danger do you have
from wild animals that can catch you off guard in case you are by
yourself? In New Zealand, the birds
stopped flying because they had no one to run away from.
There's no dangerous animals. Yeah.
Our national bird, Kiwi stopped flying and lays eggs on the
ground until English came with their dogs, cats, rats and
whistles. There were virtually no, no
predators here. The the biggest threat you can
encounter is Kia. Our native mountain parrot are
incredibly smart and ticky. If they see you landing
somewhere they will come and you see the skirt popping from
behind the rock and then you have to be careful because they
love to steal things. If you leave your I know socks
to dry, they will just steal it and then bounce away few meters
and laugh at you and you're like give it back and like, no, I
don't need your sock, but I will just enjoy the play.
So it's a it's always a very special to encounter and have
interactions with them because it's this type of wildlife that
you don't really encounter anywhere else.
That's very, very curious, very tricky, very smart bird that
also has No Fear because they never learned, they never
evolved to be afraid of anything or anyone.
So all the encounters that you can have with the wildlife in
New Zealand are very special and very beautiful and not dangerous
at all. You don't have to be worried
about any predators or anything trying to eat you or hurt you.
We just again, another reasons why all the venturing through
the New Zealand Backcountry is so much fun.
It's very safe. Also New Zealand itself is very
safe, people are super friendly and it's very easy when you
finally get to the road to hit back home or to your car and
people are extremely helpful. There's a lot going for New
Zealand, but if you're considering it maybe next
northern winter, it may be a sign to to come to New Zealand
or some flying kind of adventures.
So for all our listeners wondering if you ever get tired
of the crowded daggers and the course lines in Colombia or
Brazil, you know where to head, Uh, for all the pristine nature.
But do carry an extra pair of socks because they might get
stolen when we land somewhere. Exactly.
Got it. Ginga, I was watching your
YouTube channel and nine years ago you uploaded a video saying
paragliding in China. And lately you were uploading
some reels about paragliding in Peru.
So from China to Peru, how has the journey been?
If you can catch up our viewers, how many years have you been in
the game and amount of hours if you're comfortable, because I
think years only tell part of the story, but the hours is the
real thing. So if you can tell a little bit.
So I started flying a little more than a decade ago when I
discovered paragliding. It was immediate loss at first
flight at Dolph Head First. All in, it was never truly a
weekend hope before me. I never had the period when I
would fly on the weekends. I was working for a marketing
agency as a strategist for commercial campaigns.
It was so good. But once I discovered
paragliding within a couple of months, I quit it and I moved to
Bassano del Grappa and for next year I was flying a living off
savings that I basically didn't really have.
So living of a credit card and trying to figure out how to
maybe start making money a bit at some point.
That means that from the very first year I was flying in the
first year of my flying when I still was learning to turmoil
and basically bumping out in every field.
When you stand in Basana on the take off Tapeti and you look in
front on the flatlands, basically every field you can
point out. I probably landed there.
This is how I learned Italian, hitting back with locals and and
trying to communicate with them. And so within my first year I I
flew 300 hours just learning to thermal, which is quite
achievement during your first year because flights are short.
So you have to really keep trying, keep pushing and fly
every possibility. Since then I've been flying
around 400, sometimes more than 400 hours per year.
So it would come now to around 4000 hours.
I assume as much as you said that years don't necessarily
explain. Also at some point airtime stops
really saying so much about your flying because at the beginning
you can't check it. You need airtime, you need to
spend time in the air, you need to feel comfortable, you need to
develop muscle memory for thermalling, for for looking
around, for observation and for handling your wing.
But also there's a moment when you can just get stuck in what
they call stupid airtime. You just fly the same hill all
the time on the same lines. There's nothing wrong about it,
but it's a very different way of flying and progressing into
paragliding that. If you on the other hand go to
different places and try to fly from different take offs in
various conditions and travel around and and are not afraid to
try things and not only follow the gaggle or follow your
friends, but also try to do things alone and not being
afraid to bomb out and walk or hitchhike back or take a train
or whatever. But you can see that after a few
100 hours, this is what makes a massive difference and makes
some pilots fly this interesting, inspiring lines
that that we all like to see from the majority that will fly
the same hill or the same soaring site forever.
And again. There's nothing wrong about any
of it. We all come to paragliding and
look for various things. Sometimes it can be really
pushing boundaries of the sport and doing things and flying
blinds that no one has flown before.
Sometimes it may be chilling after a day of work on the
beautiful coast in Cancan laminar conditions.
And there's nothing wrong with any of it.
It's just really being honest about what we are looking for in
flying and what we want from it. So I've always wanted it, but it
took me quite a few years to really define it.
What is my reason for flying? But now for a few years, I know
that there are basically two things that inspire me and make
it worth for me. It's beauty and adventure.
Once I realized this, I also realized that for me personally,
blind chasing kilometers doesn't necessarily mean as much as
going to beautiful places and fly some versaniculized and
going deep in the mountains, because this usuality means both
beauty and adventure. So if I have a choice to fly
some Milky Way for kilometers and we all know that's never
played the outlines that just give on a given day, you go to
particular place in the Alps and there will be 100 other pilots
who want to fly 200 kilometer triangle on this day.
And we all go for it like a goggle and almost feels like
addition flying. And again, nothing wrong about
it. This actually can be a really
cool experience to fly with your friends, fly with others, stay
very fast and very efficiently and can break your personal
best. But this type of flying, after a
few years, I realized that it's not really something that I
remember afterwards, the something that OK, I take off X
amount of kilometers, but it wasn't really anything life
changing. So yeah, probably around 4000
hours now, maybe more. And a lot of different places, a
lot of different lines, a lot of different mountains all around
the world. You ask about China.
When I went to China, it was a little bit of spontaneous
decision for various reasons. I was a very fresh pilot.
I don't even think I was flying for two years, probably less.
So it was an adventure and very interesting as a paragliding
trip and cultural trip. China is a pretty intense place
altogether. It's also it's huge.
So it also it feels like you're immersed in the, in the
completely different universe and comparing it to, but it's
really hard to, it's really hard to compare it to.
For example, my this year's April, May in Peru in Bolivia,
because when I went to Peru in Bolivia this year, I was a very
different pilot. I was more self-sufficient and
had a much more experience than than this years ago.
And I flew various places alone and then later the couple of
friends that I met there for weeks.
I ventured with my gear through Peru, for example, basically
pointing, oh, this volcano looks great, let's try to fly over.
I'm just making it happen. Everything that I pointed out
and everything that I wanted to happen did happen.
I went to a few days Volbevaki in Bolivia, Yeah, without much
plan. I didn't even download it, all
the maps for this Vol divide, because I'd never thought that I
would go so far. So it was a real kind of real
venturing, kind of like landed somewhere now to plan out for
six. At some point I was like, I
really don't know where I am. So there's no network, no maps.
So it's just followed the Montes.
I broke, I believe in this task record on this, on this
particular Vol divide. It was on the just above 100
kilometres. But the terrain is so wild and
unexplored. Suddenly you do things that are
truly new, not only new for you, which is always exciting.
Doesn't matter if someone did it, if it's new for you, it's
always exciting. But here you're flying virgin
terrain that's very complicated, very committing, and just to
make it happen. Of course, it felt natural and
felt right. We can't come back to it because
I really believe that what feels right.
In paragliding, this doesn't feel right.
It's a very important question that we should all ask ourselves
all the time. But it felt right and it felt
relatively easy because I had this thousands of hours and
dozens of places and lines flown in different places before.
So yeah, very different trips to compare.
I love the way you explain it. I can see the excitement you
have with respect to the topic. And no wonder 4000 hours, that's
like these kind of numbers are only heard in commercial
aviation re flight and back to paragliders.
I rarely come across people who do that.
And the ones who do are the ones who are famous on Instagram and
Facebook with all the Red Bull logos and everything around
them. It's really hard paragliding.
It's such a weather depending sport and it's dependent sport
and so difficult. If you have normal life and
Monday, Friday 95 job and maybe family and other obligations,
it's so hard to have so much air time.
This is why I always admire pilots who keep chasing it.
There's plenty of pilots who chase it hard.
Having all this life on the ground and finding time for much
organization and good relationships both at work and
the family. It's always very inspiring.
But yes, to fly year after year, hundreds of hours, you basically
need to make your make it your life.
It's very hard to do it otherwise.
Yeah, I think only a handful of pilots, regardless of how
motivated they are, are ever able to get more than 100 hours
in the first year of flying. That's true.
That's pretty unique, but this is something that I'm probably I
don't even know if I'm proud of it.
It just shows how absolutely committed and in love I was with
the sport when I started flying because it basically it's like
nothing if you if. Does the the.
The moments of madness in your life then can define it.
So that was a moment of madness because I really didn't think it
through very well. My heart ruled.
The decision of moving to to Italy and flying to making this
first year fully focused on flying.
It wasn't a very obvious decision, but it simplified
everything dramatically because we all have this list of
priorities in our life and somethings matter more,
somethings matter less at this point.
There was paragliding and then there was like long break and
then there were other things. So anything and the decisions in
my life for this first year were very simple because it's like,
doesn't help my flying. Is it good for my flying?
Yes. Let's do it.
No. OK, so it's really interesting
how it may not be the easiest thing to do, but in some ways it
was very simple. It's simplified a lot of things
at this point and but of course, it's not sustainable.
I don't believe that you can have only flying in your life
and care only about this. You need other things in your
life to balance everything. You can't wrap everything about
your flying or any other passions for this matter.
That's not only unhealthy for your life as a whole, but also
sooner or later will burn you out.
We all go through ups and downs in our flying.
There's like it's never smooth journey.
There are always moments when you are the king or queen of the
world and then from here to 0 very quickly.
Maybe you get scared, maybe you see someone get hurt, maybe one
of your friends have a bad incident or accident.
There are always some setbacks and how we rebuild from them.
It's, it's, it's, it's really dependent of of the quality of
our life and the quality of our mental balance that we have also
outside of flying or if we have good people in our life, if we
have other things that flying doesn't define us as a whole, we
are more than this, yeah. These these are deep talks.
We could have a whole episode based on psychology of flying.
I really believe we don't talk about it enough.
Everybody agrees that paragliding is a mental game.
You ask anyone, Oh yes, it's mental game, everything is in
your head, etcetera. But how many pilots do you
really know that truly embrace this mental journey, that truly
trained their mind in the same way as we train ground handling
or thermaling? Sooner or later our limitation
and flying won't be technical. It won't be a wing that we need
to upgrade. It won't be a physical fitness
to stay in the air for long enough.
It will be our mindset. If we can be consistent,
focused, centre to balance and push with safety and
progression. If we can rebuild after
setbacks, if we can manage our anxiety and fear that develops
at some point. All these things are truly fully
mental. I had after first year of my
flying, actually within my first year, because I was flying so
much, everything was happening like in the speedy version of
usual progression. Within my first spring I was
already almost 200 hours because I was flying very intensively
the whole autumn and winter, maybe 100, sixty, 170 hours at
this point. At this point I believed that I
was already very experienced pilot because I was flying in
Basan a whole winter and autumn. For those of you who don't know,
it's one of the very few places in Europe where you can fly in
winter in thermic conditions. This is very particular
environment, which is like when the winter conditions are warmed
up by a by the sea and the flatlands in front of it.
You are in the mountains in Peda, Montana, in the at the
edge of Italian out. But also it doesn't necessarily
feel like mountains. There's no valley crossing.
The wind is always coming from the flatlands.
If it's coming from the back, you just don't fly.
Especially in autumn and winter. It's very gentle and very
scratchy, very, very low, very slow thermals.
After flying for whole autumn and winter in this conditions, I
became pretty efficient in them. I started believing that I'm
such a good, but not already and only in this place, only in this
conditions. And then the spring came my my
first April was very explosive. The conditions changed and I
decided, oh, Bassana, I'm bored with it.
I'm going to the Swiss Alps in April.
So I crashed on a tree and there's a lot happening there.
Within two weeks of April, I had quite a few incidents that I was
very lucky that I walked away from.
And I made a lot of bad decisions based on my hunger for
flying, but basically no clue what I was truly doing.
And so it was like a typical intermediate syndrome of
steroids plus the spring conditions on top of it.
And I got really scared. I realized that there's a lot of
things that I don't know. I developed this massive
mistrust about my decisions. So for next I can't you note for
next almost two years I was basically flying constantly
questioning myself and asking OK, that all seems all right,
but what if I'm doing something so stupid and something horrible
will happen? It can be really exhausting to
fly like this without any trust into your decisions and and.
Digging. Myself out of it took by this is
for psychologists and millions of books and and talks and
meditations and you name it. So when I work with pilots and
call them we mostly focus on flying and going to beautiful
places and flying their first 100 kilometres or particular
month. I so going for BV into a
beautiful place. But more often than not the most
important things happen on the ground when we can talk things
through and give them some framework to manage whatever
they're dealing with. We all deal with something
because I like to say that we fly the way we live.
If we have any type of anxiety, very strong inner critic put a
lot of pressure on ourself. If you are perfectionist, if you
are over analysing things on daily basis, etcetera, etcetera.
If we're if we're if we have very low self esteem or if you
are too cocky, too confident in the real life that that traits
that we can hide or manage or blame others or pretend that
they are not so important. But when we fly, they really
come out and rule our flying and rule our safety or rule our
performance. So in some ways we slide the way
we live, but also in another way this flying can and, and
managing it and looking honestly into our flying can also be a
pretty, pretty interesting journey that can positively
affect also our life on the ground and our relationships and
our work ethics and discipline and anything else.
So that's fascinating. I'm pretty passionate about it
because I think we still don't quite talk about it enough in
paragliding. We focus too much on how to
thermal the most precise way, which is of course very
important and technical part of flying.
It's super important, but also we shouldn't forget about this
mental side of it. The reason I didn't stop you was
because it was music to my ears. Listening somebody in our sport
is like, hey, we have to talk about this because this is
something that a lot of us think about, but people are in
different stages of their life or they have different
motivation to be open about it or a platform or something.
So if somebody of your stature is coming out and speaking like
this, because I've always felt that usually when I go to, I've
met instructors, a lot of them are like, yes, we can teach you
how to pull the brake to the right pressure point or how to
push the bar correctly. But nobody talks about the
psychological aspect of things. And that is, I'm so glad I've
reached out to you because this is exactly the topic that I
wanted to speak about. And talking about priorities
going, I know that I'm going to be breaking your thought process
for a second, but I really want to backtrack because your
journey started here as, as I was checking about a section on
your website where where you said that before aviation came
into your life, you were a Master of Science and physics
and pursuing APHD in solid-state spectroscopy.
If I was saying it correctly, that seems like a tongue
twister. How does a PhD candidate have
the guts and the courage relieve discomfort of whatever money
that is coming in and manifest something that is totally
uncertain? I mean, I know the pull, I know
the fascination that you have for aviation.
But if, if you can talk to our listeners about the thought
process that was strong enough to pull you out of the comfort
zone that you had of, of a career in physics and then chase
this completely, you know something else which was super
exciting and super rewarding. So I always wanted to become a
physicist since I was 10. I always wanted to discover the
mysteries of nature. Now I think I'd simply chose my
specialization a little bit. Unfortunately, because the
solid-state physics, as much as it's pretty interesting.
It's basically about how the world, how the matter around us
works on the very, very microscopic level, what's
happening there on the electron level.
I didn't quite I didn't quite appreciate that when I'll get
into actual research on my PhD, I already knew it more or less
when I was doing mustache thesis that that because I chose
spectroscopy, it means that basically you need the
laboratory and this laboratory has to be pretty dark the way
all the other types of radiation, including visible
light. So in practice, what it means
that you're spending your life in a dark basement.
As much as the topic itself is interesting, this kind of
lifestyle was never really my thing and in some point I just
lost passion for it. I left my PHDI never finished
it. I bought one way tickets to
Asia. At this point I wasn't a pilot.
I was a very keen rock climber, so all my life outside of
physics was wrapped around climbing.
At some point you get into this diet and microcycles and
microcycles and training and holiday plans and all your
friends are basically connected to climbing.
So it was a big part of my life. So but one ticket, one way
ticket went to India and went Thailand for climbing.
Then came back got a corporate job which was very well paid and
I absolutely hated it. So I didn't last long.
Then in a big business consulting company and started
working for a for a marketing agency.
And then and all this I knew that paragliding existed but I
never and until now a lot of a lot of people who are not
connected to free flying surfing the same way about paragliding.
Because once few years back I was in at Lago de Garda, the
famous rock climbing spot and on the rest day I hiked Montebaldo.
And again for those of you who don't know it's Lago de Garda
and Montebaldo but it's a famous siv and acro place.
Plenty of pilots come to train over water and, and that's what
I saw, that's just saw all these pilots taking off and flying
over the lake and then you just lose sight of them.
So I guess it's nice. You don't have to hike down.
You can just fly down. Maybe when I'm retired, when I
can't climb anymore, because obviously climbing is so much
cooler than just flying off. Also seems really grumpy and
true. Now, I know that they were
probably stressed before the SIV.
Yeah, but they all seemed really serious.
And I was like, doesn't look like so much fun.
They don't look like they're having too much fun.
One day, I'll try. So that was my concept of
paragliding for a few years. And then I was training pretty
hard for my rock climbing, and I fell off the boulder in a weird
way. I injured my elbow a little bit.
Ripped. Yeah, not even totally, Just
needed a few months of break without climbing.
I was devastated because my. Life is climbing what?
Can I do so because my body was so used to training?
I started running a lot and this is basically how I got into
endurance sports. They progressed from running a
few kilometers to 5 to 15 every morning.
I was a little bit obsessive and when I get into something, I
really get into it. It ended up with some ultra
marathons and then red blue Subs in the end, but something was
missing. I was very fit but very
unhealthy, but physically and emotionally and mentally.
But then a friend of mine just did the paragliding course and
said we should try to do it. It's pretty fun.
And there was like long weekends or some Easter or whatever and I
was like, I have nothing else to do.
I can, I can't climb unfortunately.
So I'll do my paragliding course.
And from the very first moment you hike this little hill,
training hill and go with a paraglider and then fly over
this first slides are not even flies are like little hops.
Yeah, yeah, a few meters above the ground.
But for me, the concept that you can actually hike with the
backpack and open this piece of cloth and fly with it.
It just do my mind. It's something ticked that just
like, OK, so you can actually do the things.
It gives you a freedom in it and then the rest is history.
I moved to Basano, my first terminal in Basano.
Finally, without falling out of it.
I was alone in the terminal into the cloud base.
I landed with tears in my eyes. It was some mystical experience
for me. From this moment, I was
completely hooked. I was like, Oh my God, that's
the most beautiful thing ever. Finally was flying.
I wasn't just slowly falling. I wasn't jumping like kite
surfing, just up and down or whatever.
I was actually climbing using force of nature to this
invisible element of air to go up and and go somewhere with
that. It completely blew my mind and
since then I've been chasing it pretty hard.
I like to say that flying in some ways saved me because I was
in a very dark place when I started flying and it really
healed my soul. It proves to me that if there is
so much beauty or so much magic that you can have, it feels
almost unreasonable to be said if it makes sense, or it feels
almost stupid not to chase it and not to try to get this
feeling as much as possible. So in some ways it was addictive
from this first thermal. I completely believe you that
that was the case with me. Although I cannot boast about
having 300 hours in the first year, I think I had 60 or
something. But one thing that comes to my
mind, Kinga, is that you are a very honest person when it comes
to sharing. And from what I see on your
website, it's all written out very transparently where you
don't hide your mistakes. The the hiccups that I've come
across as you shared your Basano or the Switzerland adventure
that you had Swiss Alps that you had in the April.
So being honest is something that is super important in our
lifestyles at various stages. And it helps being honest.
Let's say if you were training too much, you have to be honest
and say that regardless of how much effort I'm putting, it has
been counterproductive. And same honesty is very
important when it comes to chasing airtime.
But regardless of how much risk I am chasing, this is becoming
too much to handle and I should pull back.
Has there been something with you that has helped you stay
honest with yourself and eventually, which I can see has
reflected in shaping you, who you are of today?
Because I see a lot of pilots, including me.
It's very hard to admit your mistakes.
It's very hard to say that yes, I messed up and I should not be
doing it again or I will not do that again.
How have you navigated that aspect of life during all these
years from the beginning to now? That's a very interesting
question. No one actually asked me this
question before I. Don't believe?
That it's even possible to truly fly for years sustainably and
not get burnt out, not lose the passion, just constantly find
joy in it if you are not honest with yourself.
Like we can lie as much as we want, but flying will just show
us who we are and doesn't matter.
All the narratives that we create in our daily life, all
the masks that we wear to show maybe at work or maybe to
potential partners who we want to be doesn't matter.
Because you fly and it it immediately shows you who you
are. All your insecurities, all your
false narratives, all your wannabe stories that will all
come out. And we are very vulnerable out
there. We are very exposed not only to
elements but also to our to consequences of our decisions.
So if we are not honest about it to ourselves, because it's not
all we always thinks about being honest to others, but first of
all, it's about being honest to ourselves, We really can't
progress in the safe and sustainable manner.
And I think we all have met these pilots who will always,
for example, find excuses. Oh, what happened?
What did you land? Oh, it was really turbulent.
And you're like, it wasn't. But I know that you're flying
the Super hot wink. Maybe it's not the great wink
for you at this point. But instead of addressing it,
instead of addressing your anxiety or fear or whatever
else, you are just finding excuses that the conditions
weren't great or just it's a wink or it's a face of the moon
or anything else. So it's, it's really without
addressing our emotion, it's really hard to to go anywhere in
my opinion. And again, it doesn't mean that
we all need to dig in this and our mindset and emotions again
and again. We are all wired differently.
So we process things in different ways.
Some people need to talk things through and then they can truly
think through them. Some people need to think them
through, hide in The Cave and then they can express what's
bothering them or what's important, what not.
So we processing differently. I definitely process through
talking and within this life of journeys, I talked about
paragliding a lot and I'm very privileged to have a very good
partner in life who truly understands what I do and what's
important for me and lessons and always has a good input when I
need it. So we like to think about
paragliding in this as this lonely journey, but it doesn't
have to be. We all need other humans.
If you have someone who cares about you or someone who
understands. What all this journey is about,
and it may be of course, is the easiest if you're talking to
other paragliding pilot, but it may be also someone who knows
you very well who doesn't have to be a pilot or someone who has
a background in other sports like whitewater kayaking, rock
climbing or mountaineering. If you're someone that you can
honestly talk things through, for me, that's always very
important and very helpful. And the first time you do it,
the first time you encounter some set back, it takes a lot to
process it because you don't have tools yet to, to be
vulnerable and honest and find this constructive solution to,
to, to it. But every next time, and there
will be next times, because every time we think, oh, now I
have it all sorted. I went from my intermediate
syndrome. Now it's all sorted.
No, it's not. If you are keep growing with the
sport and keep progressing and keep challenging yourself,
you'll always encounter new new challenges and new setbacks and
new issues that you will have to process.
But every next time will be easier because because you
already developed tools and you know who you are and what you
want from the sport and what the dynamics of the sport is.
It's actually pretty, pretty interesting because I mentioned
that my this my first sandbag, my intermediate syndrome was
pretty brutal on me on various ways.
And it took me basically two years of couple of years of
struggle and constant feeling like maybe I should quit the
spark because I wasn't flying as well.
I wasn't committed. I was afraid.
I was constantly questioning myself.
It was exhausting. So maybe I just need a break so
I won't fly for a few days, but then I was.
Staring in the sky. And thinking, oh, I should be
flying it's it was exhausting. It took me a long time of
constant processing and reading and learning and and meditating
and talking about it to, to process it and, and to reconnect
fully to, to flying. Not even reconnect, just connect
in the new level to it. Because you never come back to
the safety process something like this.
You never come back to where you started.
You, you. Jump to the next level.
We like to think that's a linear progression.
The more we fly, the more we put into it, the better we fly.
But it never is. It's most like some crazy drunk
sinusoid. You take 2 steps forward and
wants to back and then completely plateau for a while
and there's a lot happening on the way.
This being said now after all this years, a few weeks ago I
had the really unexpected and very brutal collapse which was
the the ugliest collapse I actually encounter within this
4000 hours. For years since flying 2 liners
nothing like this happened to me.
I was flying in the list side, which itself is no goal, I know,
but also multi flying happens in the list side often.
And the big art of multi flying is to understand which list
sites are acceptable and which list sites are bad.
So this one was surprisingly strong, surprisingly ugly and
very sharp and was getting out of it and on the edge.
I got a bit collapsed. I was very close to the terrain
it went in total rotation and my muscle memory, my reaction saved
me from some bigger drama. However, I I did crash landed on
the terrain. Yeah, it's not that I opened it
and flew away. It's also not that I got hurt.
I I walked away from it, but that was definitely way closer
than anyone should come. If you touch the terrain when
you didn't plan to, that's obviously a very close call.
And it shook me in various ways, especially because I started
feeling more comfortable within the last years and because I
didn't really expect it to happen with such a force.
So the sport has a constant tendency of every time you feel
too comfortable or too complacent or confident, it will
just slap you in the face, like, hey, we'll show you your place.
And this is something I needed to process a little bit to
regain the trust to myself, to the wink, which of course was a
wings fault. It was my fault.
But reconnect to not to be too sketchy.
But this took a few days, not few years.
If something like this happened when I was a 50 hour pilot, I
would need way longer to get over it.
So what I'm trying to say here is that the setbacks and better
worse moments will keep happening.
Everyone that who tells you that they have it all sorted, that
never get scared, that never even like everything they they
have it all sorted. Basically they either lie or
they are just don't push themselves in various ways so
they always fly deep within the comfort zone.
Again, nothing wrong about it, but also there's not much
learning or progression happening there at this point
and or they are just waiting for their next mishap to happen.
Every time we say I have it all sorted, nothing can touch me.
Every time we start feeling untouchable, this part will show
us that we are very much touchable and very much mortal.
That's nothing tragic about this, it's just a beauty of life
going deep in the philosophical theme.
But also, it's not something that should stop us from doing
something that we love. Jeez, I'm but loss of words.
I think I need to compile all of this and let the listeners do
the same a little bit. It's most Marieties hearing a
top level pilot being so honest. A lot of people in today's world
don't share things as transparently as you do.
And that was the whole point of bringing out paragliding at this
podcast, that we as community do not share or talk about
difficult topics as much as we talk about fun or topics.
So that was the whole point that we really need to start being
open about this. And also it doesn't mean that
it's all struggle and difficult choices and and meditation every
morning. Of course there is like majority
of flying is just pure joy that if you are in a good place in
your flying, you may think what is she even talking about?
I'm totally enjoying my flying without all this BS.
But sooner or later most of us go through some darker parts and
then we truly appreciate. Oh OK, so this is what happened.
This is moment when I had to take a step back, be honest,
talk to someone I trust and the breath starts slowly.
Maybe if I'm really scared, maybe fly only in the mornings,
only in the evenings, only in the place.
And maybe I need to downgrade my wing, come back to AB wing or a
wing or whatever, just to refine this joy of flying.
Because in the end, we all want to have fun out there and the
sport is potentially dangerous or risky, especially if we do
some dumb stuff. It's expensive, it's real time
consuming, it can be stressful, it takes time from from your
other obligations in life. So it's a very committing sport.
And if it's not fun, what's the point?
What are we trying to prove here?
The point is that sometimes to make it fun, we need to take a
step back and go through some uncomfortable journeys.
And we shouldn't be afraid of it and we shouldn't be ashamed of
it in any way. That's all I think, yeah.
Yeah, and I think with the reducing attention spans due to
social media, I see them, Spotify Analytics where I host
my podcast, a lot drop out in the 1st 10 minutes.
So anybody who has stuck so far is definitely understanding what
we are saying because first of all, they know what is the
essence of pushing. The comfort zone is where the
smile really starts coming onto your face because comfort zone
is exciting for the first few days, but after that it's the
most boring place to be in life. On the air or on the ground,
wherever you think so. In the way.
We all search for flow, don't we?
And the flow only this magical moment when we know that we are
doing something exciting, feel fully focused and present, and
it pushes us, but also it doesn't create this anxiety.
So we're all looking for flow in life.
And if you want to experience it, it's very addictive.
But to experience it again and again, you can't chase it
recklessly because this is where we put ourselves in trouble.
But also, you don't want to live without it if you experience it.
And to experience it again, we need to constantly expand our
comfort zone, try new things and do new things.
So yeah, here is to to a lot of flow in 2025.
This is so nice. I think we'll use this as a
tagline of my show. A lot of flow in 2025.
Yeah, I was going to save this topic for a little bit later in
the show, but I think we have just reached a point where I
feel super comfortable asking about this.
Parallel lighting is something, as you said, it takes a lot, not
just from you, it takes a lot from your money, from your bank
account, from your social life. It's an investment and it's
equally rewarding. I'm, I'm not denying like 7 or 8
billion on the planet and a handful of them chase airtime in
collapsible wings and a handful of them push their comfort zone.
The lucky few of us who are blessed enough to chase airtime
like this do find ourselves in situations where our support
system does not understand what we're doing.
Support systems like close friends and family.
Finding our own tribe is a whole different struggle because
obviously you have to move geographically to different
societies, to different countries, to invest in visas
and monetary situations and everything.
A lot of times it's very easy to say no matter what comes, I'm
going to go back to my passion and let it fulfil my life.
Now, the thing with that is, regardless of how rewarding it
might sound, there are very easy ways to become a loner in the
sport while chasing your passion at the highest level.
Because you want to chase your hundred 200 hours, but you can't
convince a friend who flies to give up his lifestyle and his
support system. And then you're like, all right,
then I might as well do it by myself.
So when you're doing this by yourself because that is the
only option life has given you, it's either that or lowering
your expectations or giving up, which of course is not a point
if you're chasing it that hard. How does one navigate their
challenges when chasing the pinnacle of their dream by
themselves and not having anybody to talk to?
Well, it's not a very. Interesting question that that
no one has ever asked. That's a very good one actually.
So there's a few approaches to it because we're wired
differently. Not everyone's looking for the
same thing in life and then flying the people who are very
heavily community driven and for them flying with you, you know
that you're the type of person if the best flights you can
think of were flights with your friends, flying as a little gag
or as a team going somewhere and doing something together, this
is pretty obvious. Your pilot.
You are aware that flying is is in some way lonely sport because
at the end, even if you're surrounded by friends, you are
an aircraft in the air. So whatever is happening, it's
your decisions and your responsibility, but you are
driven by sharing this experience with others.
There are people driven by adventure or beauty in my case.
There's a very distinctive type of pilots who are very
competitive. If it's a World Cup or your
local club on Sunday, if you out fly your friends in the friendly
competition, you are the happiest camper out there.
We all in some ways look for different things and it can
drive the way you find your tribe.
Few ways of. Approaching it on one hand, I
believe that if you show who you are out there, if you do your
thing, and in some ways it was my case that when I started
flying, I had people around me in Basana and there's a lot of
pilots and I had a good weekend. Mentors that would suggest
something when I was a beginner or give me some advice from
their perspective. It's good to have people around
you and bounce your experience of them, but in some ways I was
really driven so much by flying that I wasn't looking for a
community, if it makes sense. I was always a little bit of a
loner. I was alone when I started
flying. I was alone when I moved to move
to France from Italy because I didn't want to find Basana
anymore. I had enough of it.
But Swiss Alps in April was a little bit too much.
I moved to France for summer. And sooner or later when you
follow your passion, your tribe organically finds you if it
makes sense. So it's not so much that you
desperately find it trying to find your tribe, but your tribe
will find you and like minded pilots will or like minded
humans will naturally connect with who you are.
It's a little bit like be yourself because otherwise the
people who are looking for you won't be able to find you by
being honest, vulnerable and and chasing whatever is important
for you. I believe that we are just
naturally getting closer to other like minded people who are
looking for similar things. Of course it's a little bit
different when you are talking to her about already existing
type of your family or friends who don't understand flying, who
don't connect to it in any way and can't really understand why
you justify the risk you take or all the time that you spent
doing it if it's really worth it.
Who are trying to maybe blame you in put you into kind of this
guilt state for not spending enough time with them.
And this is extremely tricky because it all depends.
At the end it would be nice to say if they truly care about you
they will understand at least what you're saying.
But in reality, we are coming from different backgrounds and
have different types of tribes around us, so they may still
truly not understand why you do what you do.
This is very tricky because in some way life is really about
compromise and priorities. If at this point your family's
happiness is something that that you can't sort out or can't
solve different way, then something has to give.
Maybe flying has to give for this time period of time, or
maybe the family has to be sat down and truly explained what
it's all about. Maybe they need to understand
how beautiful and special is what you are doing.
Maybe they need a little bit of connection to to to why you find
it so special. Maybe you need to tone down the
risk taking to keep them happy but still enjoy the flying.
So it is a very complex topic. For me when I started flying it
was all easy. I had no children, no husband,
no partner, my mum. Has never, truly.
Understood what I'm doing out there.
Until she flew condom I think she never truly connected the
few years later. Why would I again find another
spot that takes you even higher? You can fall from even higher
altitude. Why would you do something like
this? Of course it's easier when you
have no obligations holding you back.
You can just jump into it. From this perspective it's easy
for me to say you will do what you want to do.
And this is literally what I was doing for a first year.
I was chasing it so hard, nothing else mattered.
Of course, I met a lot of great people on the way, but if the
flying was better somewhere else, if the season would, I
would just leave it all behind. Flying had the priority.
As we said at the beginning, that was flying and then
anything else. And in some ways it sounds
almost heartless, but the same time we all have to be very
honest what's in our top of our priority list at this point and
what's in 2nd and 3rd place. So I didn't all the IT, it is
sometimes the prices that you create some friendships and meet
your people and then it all dissipates because you chase
something else at this point or they chase something else at
this point. But they really believe that if
you show yourself out there and be vulnerable and and honest
about your flying and about what you want from it, the more
honest you are, the more your tribe will find you very
organically. So again, I don't know if it
really explains it because it's a very complex topic and it's
really heavily dependent on your situation.
It's very different when you're coming from some very
traditional and risk averse background and your family
absolutely hates the concept of you flying paragliders.
And it's very different when you are like 20 something and and no
obligations, no really no family, no no job.
Even better than you have to sort out how to pay for all
this. But I didn't still have all the
freedom to do as you wish and find your tribe organically.
At this point I've been migrating for a few years with
trips to different places like Peru and Bolivia that you
mentioned, but I've been migrating between New Zealand,
Europe and Indian Himalayas for years now.
Each of these places has tribe and my people, but India is very
particular because we only go for a few weeks.
We reconnect with dear friends that we deeply care about,
honest beautiful friendships. We go flying together and have
heaps of fun. Then we don't see each other for
the rest of the year. So yeah, it all has its price
and space, I think. This is a question that
everybody has to find an answer for themselves, no matter.
But also because we are all different and we have different
situations and the different, different priorities.
So in some ways to answer this question, everyone needs to ask
themselves what's truly important for me.
And there's a bunch of very important questions that I
answered multiple times. But also, sometimes I give my
pilots their basic, very important questions.
For example, who am I? What do I want and what am I
afraid of? What's important?
And these are questions that are so basic that when I ask you,
oh, what's important for you and in there.
You'll probably say but. What do you mean?
What do you want in flying, private life or work?
Because we create different narratives and want a lot of
things when you give it true space.
I like to do it in particular on solo missions.
So you spend a day, 2 days somewhere in the woods alone.
I like to fast going into some more extreme ways of finding
your growth and flow. Then you don't have any
distractions. The point is to get away from
all the distractions if you can for a day or two.
My first solo was three days. That was pretty hardcore.
Seven to two hours in the forest without food.
It can be the few hours, it can be 15 minutes of yoga and then
answering these questions, just giving your mind a bit of space
and lack of distractions. Because we live our lives in
such a you mentioned social media, we are constantly
distracted. We are constantly telling or
listening to stories, talking, writing, scrolling, listening to
things. We no one sits and drinks their
coffee anymore without doing anything else.
We have to read something, we have to watch something.
So our brain is not didn't evolve to do this.
So we are constantly overwhelmed and overloaded information and
narratives to give yourself a few hours, maybe a day, without
distractions. Give your mind space to wander,
get bored, and then answer this very basic question.
Suddenly it really jumps at you. Suddenly you know exactly what's
important, You know exactly what you want.
You don't create narratives, it just comes up at you.
There are very basic questions, too basic to answer them.
For example, what do you want? And then, bam, here this because
there's too much noise around us.
But also once we honestly answer these questions, we can navigate
things like the question you ask how to find a compromise between
your passion for flying and the families that that doesn't
understand and accept it. And it can be something pretty
surprising. But the answer will be different
to any for everyone because every situation and every human
is different. Yeah.
And I think the take away was just sitting with your own
thoughts and cleaning out the distractions for some time.
That is the wonder drug, which I kid you not, will be sold in
pharmacies in time to come in some way or the other.
Because the amount, yeah. It's an incredible, powerful,
powerful tool. There's no way I want to stop on
this this topic, but we have to move on for the sake of the
show. I quickly want to touch upon the
topic of materialistic wealth, Kinga, because that is something
all of us have to answer at some point in time.
Gliders are getting more expensive than ever.
But I think I was just speaking with a sailplane pilot and he
was telling me the amount of money he spends per hour if he
chases airtime for about 60 to 100 hours was a bit cheaper than
the amount of money I was spending as a paraglider pilot.
It's the same amount of airtime. Yeah, I'm.
I'm not, I kid you not, because they're renting the planes.
They're not buying the planes. Yeah, but still you need to
rent. So basically you pay per hour
for toll for rental and cetera. Please do not quote.
Me on on this to any of my listeners, but all I'm saying is
the price point was. Expensive.
The the spot is expensive. That's true.
We all know it. Yeah.
So let's say the beginning years for anyone.
This is not just for you or me or for Kriegel Maurer or any of
the top line pilots. But anybody who's starting such
an expensive sport is going to face the question of money at
some point in time, either on the first year or second year or
the 5th year before finally a Red Bull and all of these big
companies started associating with you and there was a way
forward. How were you managing the
materialistic side of things when you were chasing solely
your passion? Poorly.
Jeez I love your honesty thing. You're a podcaster?
Was believed to be honest. Poorly.
Right. We all do.
We all do. We just want to know how did you
do it and still make it so that we we can follow your footsteps.
With being in depth seasonal work and and prioritizing pretty
heavily. So we were for our first few
years since I met my partner that was we met in Anasi.
It was basically after my first year flying.
He originally brought me to New Zealand.
He's a New Zealander. He's Kiwi born and raised and in
New Zealand fly as well. He does fly.
So we were it's always a little bit easier.
I would say that let's say double income or single income
at times, or two, two half incomes and no more gadgets, no
kids, no other aspects. You can live pretty cheaply.
We've been living together or I've been living alone from van
for years. He's been travelling in the van
and living on the van and wild camping somewhere in the bushes.
This year I got an house in Italy.
Now we'll have a base and so, so big house.
So it will need a little bit of TLC tender loving care.
The house is between Felter and Bassano basically.
So there's plenty of beautiful places around that you can fly
and just fly new places, new conditions with different types
of pilots and learn more within the same time.
So that's one of the concepts. But coming back to the not a big
business just a little bit to make this life sustainable, but
also a big part of it. From my perspective, it's always
isn't easy because I don't need much when sense of comfort.
I don't mind all the discomfort that comes with one life for
months and living very cheaply. I don't need fancy handbags,
dresses and dinners out. So this itself can really make
it way more sustainable. And I'm not the only one that
maybe now it's not exactly they're bugging like it used to
be. Since I coach quite a bit and
work with pilots, that's evolved a little bit.
But for years it was what we would call glamorous dirt,
bugging and flying as much as possible and chasing the
conditions. It's not.
Also. Awful because for example, van
life in the Alps, it's amazing when you want to be mobile and
chase the weather. So if you want to prioritize
your flying, a couple of years of van life, definitely if you
can do it with your life, it's definitely not the worst choice.
But again, it's not something that anyone that can just spark
their life in a van and do it. Some people have other
obligations and other life out there that they have to
compromise on. Yes.
So how did you manage it? Poorly but the same time
happily? I'll tell you something I find
interesting after few years of of van life.
The more comfortable we are, the lazier we get in general, the
more we focus. I experience it.
Working for a big consulting company is an other side of the
extreme because you work with the people who are very success
driven. This work is their life and it
translates into money. There's good money in it and at
the end, time is ultimate value in life.
Everything else we can buy our exchange.
But time, once it happens, you can get it back.
So we are basically selling our time for whatever else we are
doing. This is what all the job
relationships are. You are selling your time and
expertise for the money and then you buy all the things that
other people around you have. Old car, you have to have a
flash one or you can't live here, you have to live there,
etcetera. So it creates this kind of
vicious cycle of wanting more and having more.
And again, if it works for you, that's fantastic, but usual it
takes a lot of time and also it puts your focus into owning and
not experiencing the simplifying things.
Doesn't have to be extreme as living in a van for a whole
summer and spring, but simplifying things, maybe
downsizing, maybe getting rid of all this external expectations
and focusing on on experiencing things, on maybe travelling.
If you see or think maybe your family or or friends
relationships really switches the whole narrative.
Suddenly you realize that you really don't need so much
comfort. The discomfort that you
experience, for example, when you live in the van, you get
used to it and then when you go into the mountains or run out of
food, it doesn't bother you so much because you are not used to
being pampered daily. We naturally, as human beings
evolve to gravitate toward comfort food, high sugar food,
and safety. This is why we have to force
ourselves to go to the gym, but we don't have to force ourselves
to eat another chocolate. This one comes easily the more
we somehow and the more we in in some ways it's about going back
to bases. The more we live the simpler
life without this expectation that we need to own and gather
more, the more it can affect our life and give us more time for
things that bring us true joy, like flying and meaningful
relationships. Again, everyone's different, the
situation will always be different, but the more we free
our life from this unnecessary ballast and this is again
something that that everyone can can waste in their own mind.
How much we want to sacrifice and how important flying is or
how important this new car or new fantasy TV is for us.
As long as we are honest with ourselves.
And it's, it's the only point that I think the whole
conversation can be summarized as like, be honest with yourself
and truly honest how uncomfortable it may be.
And whatever comes out of it, just follow it and you can't go
wrong. I'm checking this.
Totally get it. And and that that's why I was, I
was so fascinated when when we brought out the topic of honesty
because it is so hard to just live in your own bubble and make
your own reality. But I think I have decoded a
simpler way of putting it across to the audiences and that is if
you can hold your horses while upgrading a new wing or if you
can make better decisions while buying that harness that you
don't need buying that radio just because everybody else is
buying that two liner C, just because the whole paragliding
population is exploding and saying we're going to buy those
two liner C. So if you can influence these
decisions then the money is going to be much more sorted in
your life. But coming back to this reality
for a moment, I would say that from what I see in the community
and and around me, there are two ways of successful.
Again, there's always Alex Obey, who has very successful company
and family. He flies 10 times per year and
200 it's 250 two 180 kilometres in the Alps, handpicking his
very best days. He can do it because he's been
flying for a long time and he's a very good pilot.
When you start, you can't really cheat the airtime.
You need to spend time putting some groundwork in.
But in general, there are there are two basic ways how a pilot
successfully merge flying with earning a living.
One is earning money through flying.
So either becoming an instructor or tandem pilot or or if
accuracy of thing maybe SAV instructor, maybe some ex
coaching safaris. This is one way of being or
becoming a professional athletes sponsored by big company.
But another way of approaching it is to find a way to have the
flexibility of your job that's completely not connected to
flying. So either if you are in IT
consulting your translator or anything else that you may be
doing that has some flexibility in it, or you might be
landscaping, but have an agreement with your boss that if
it's a really good day for flying, you can go and fly.
So to having this flexibility in which I agree it's not as easy
as finding a 9:00 to 5:00 Monday to Friday job.
If you can have some flexibility or work three days out of a week
or four days and have a longer weekend or flexible weekend
etcetera. And it comes at the cost of
maybe lower pay. This is usually what makes
pilots the best possible because.
Let's be honest, flying. Professional, either flying
tandems or guiding or being an instructor is necessarily for
everyone. For some pilots, there's this
very valid question, What if I make my passion my job and then
I lose the passion because it's now it's my job and balancing
it. It's, it's also another
question. So it's not necessarily that
everyone should become a tandem pilot from now on.
Big part of it is just maybe trying to find a little bit of
flexibility in your life and have a bit more time for flying.
So not to be so frustrated. It's not very often.
It's doesn't have to be necessarily even flexibility in
the sense that you work less very often.
It's just if it's possible to have some flexibility within the
time frame, because then you can have a weekend on Monday and
Monday is usually for some reason the best day of the week.
So. Yeah.
I don't know if it's if it helps, but again, it's 1 of this
really interesting but also really broad questions that will
be that answer will be different for every pilot.
Yes, every question we come up by saying you can find the
answer within yourself after taking the cues from the.
It is because. There's some real hard work for
flying, like you need to learn to thermal efficiently, you need
to learn weight shift, you need to learn you need to learn to
land in various conditions, to judge the winds, to understand
the methodology. There's a lot of things that you
just need to do to be able to fly safely and successfully, but
it's not. The next step is just parallel
journey where you take your flying and what truly will rule.
So there's this basic groundwork that you have to do.
You need to start flying away from your local heel and
etcetera. But there's also this parallel
journey that's you need to find your reasons why is it worth it?
Why do you love it and where do you want to take it?
This is one of the questions that I always ask my pilots
where, what's the ultimate goal? Where do you imagine yourself as
a pilot in the years? What type of pilot do you want
to become? What's truly triggers you for
flying? If you can't fail and the Sky's
the limit, where would you like to take your flying?
And it's always interesting because the answers very
heavily. So when I say that it really
depends on the pilot, it's not that I'm trying to avoid
answering. It truly is.
And I say it again and again, when I work with my pilots, they
come for so many various reasons and want to do so many different
things with their flying. All these reasons are absolutely
valid. It's just finding your reason.
Indeed, just listening to your inner voice and then making
peace with it and being honest about that.
At the. Bottom of it and also not being
afraid to re evaluate because something that might have been
super important at the beginning few years later may cause
burnout and then you realise I love competing but now I don't
want to compete anymore. Now I want to focus on my scenic
flights or whatever. So flying tandem with my kids or
anything else. And it's perfectly fine too.
Not be afraid of changing it and not being too attached.
To the identity that we, we all. Live through different
identities and wear this masks and then we create some persona
that that is a successful business man or successful
parent or successful competition pilot and present detaching from
it and not being afraid to to re evaluate and reinvent yourself.
That's a really powerful tool to have.
There's quite a lot of courage and confidence, but also a lot
of honesty. I think I'm I'm going to name
the title of this show with something related to honesty
because that is what it is. I I love the thought provoking
discussion. I think awesome.
I think I would like to give our listeners a change of topic
because this is definitely a thought provocation for
everybody, including me. I'm like, as you're narrating
this, I'm just like, my decision, is this podcast going
to work? Can I try and make a living out
of paragliding in Europe? Is this going to be the six
years down the lane as well? I think to say yeah, but being
honest is the simplest answer that I'll stick to.
So everything is sorted and that end, that king, I want to touch
up on the good side of the glorious.
The glamour, the Exiles, the professional photographs, the
Instagram reels, the crazy music that comes with it and all the
amazing edits that make us want to be you.
Every time man I see see you through the 6-7 inch phone.
Screen. Talk to us about the better side
of being famous and rich. Does it make you rich or richer
or like how does that slide? Oh, it definitely doesn't make
you. Rich If you want to become rich,
choose another. Don't make.
Flying your profession definitely want to make you
rich. If you can quickly touch upon
how does lifestyle as a paraglider pilot change when
something as big as red bullets Alps comes into you?
How many free wings and reserves and everything else?
Do you get? Oh, so definitely I'm very
privileged to be sponsored and supported by some paragliding
companies, especially by fee paragliders, which gave me
multiple wings very generously. And and I absolutely love the
whole love the wings, but also the wholesomeness and and the
focus on details and the philosophy of the company.
Harnesses by Bogdan Soy, very cool lightweight harnesses in
different colours. Again, another little
manufacturer that really listens to the feedback.
And every next product it's a better version of the.
Previous one, which is really cool to see because a lot of big
companies sometimes get settled in their groove and they get
into this concept that they know everything the best.
So it's really cool to collaborate with companies that
listen to feedback and establish is the owner of fee and the head
designer. He's been designing wings longer
than in my life, so he really knows what he's doing.
But still he listens to feedbacks and he's always chorus
and he's very passionate about it.
So this is something super inspiring to be a part of.
Generally, gear sponsorships are super helpful.
I get the gear from intense outdoors little New Zealand
company. I get my favorite fly like
glasses from Fluga little various super lightweight, real
precise various from Stoddeo. So this Libby.
Beep or ultra beep or blue beep? Thinks this is what they make.
So gear is absolutely obviously massive support, especially that
I slide so much that I go through a lot of gear.
So of course it makes a massive difference and deserves all the
gears that I would buy otherwise.
So it's pretty this part is probably tricky if you want to
get sponsored, how desperate you are about it, or if you troll
this part, that you'll take anything.
It doesn't matter what the company is or if you really have
the comfort of working with the companies you would support
otherwise. And now they're supporting you.
That's a pretty special privilege.
I need to work to sustain myself.
It's not that anyone's paying me for flying.
Even the best pilots in the world can't fully.
Even. Kragen doesn't fully sustain
himself from from sponsorships so it just shows you how even
some of the best and most accomplished pilots that we all
look up to still need to in a flight tandems guide or do other
things to sustain themselves. This needs to be said because
it's not soccer, it's not rugby, it's not Sprint running.
It's not an Olympic. Sport, it's a still a pretty
niche sport if you if you imagine that I will try super
hard and then I will qualify to Red Bull exhaust and from now on
I will live off my flying and they will pay me for adventures.
No, that's not usual how it works.
So yeah, does it answer the question or?
Partially. Because I wanted a honest
opinion, the real opinion about what the glamorous side look
like. And I think you you answered it
pretty. Well, so yeah, from my
perspective, I absolutely love my life.
I've never been happier. But it doesn't come from money,
it comes from having more or less sustainable life again.
Not really needing much. But for me the ultimate value is
time. I don't want to spend my life in
a cubicle now when I retired at 65 or 70.
I can do other things because I won't be capable of doing the
things I'm capable of doing now. I won't get this time back.
For me, the glamour comes from this.
It's not the glamour of having more, the having of the newest
gear and the fanciest, the fanciest entourage.
Yeah, it's more about having the glamour or the real wealth for
me is just having time for doing what I love and also sharing it
with others because let's be honest, this work that I do with
pilots incredibly satisfying because it's about sharing.
After many years of flying and ties and virturing for some wild
montice and going for some wild adventures, you can get used to
it a little bit and you have to push pretty hard to.
Actually to get this. Tickle of excitement in the same
way, so it doesn't happen every day.
And if you work with pilots and see how much excitement the
first Volbevac or the first flights through New Zealand
Backcountry or some other mountains, how special it is for
them and how much excitement creates.
Yeah, for me, this is glamour because this is really I, I
reconnect again and again how special it is and how privileged
we are to be doing what we're doing and how grateful we should
all be on daily basis for being capable of doing it.
So this gratefulness or gratitude is something that I
believe that if we connect to, we can be truly content.
It's something that took me years of flying to connect to,
but I believe that it's a true wealth because we like to in a
like modern society, we really like to measure everything with,
with zeros in your bank account. But at the end, there's a lot of
things that. It may be a little bit higher on
your priority list or a lot of things that don't need this
extra zeros to to make you happy.
You know that there's a lot of research that indicates that
there's particular level of wealth which is lower than you
would expect. If you get wealthier, you get
happier. Because if you're constantly
concerned how you're going to feed your family, how you're
going to pay your rent, not to get evicted, not to get
homeless, how you're going to survive until next month, of
course it creates stress. You can't be happy if you
constantly struggle with basics. But above this very modest
level, there's no correlation anymore.
So once your basic needs are fulfilled, food and and shelter
basically, and you can feed your family anything above it, it's
just indulging yourself in owning it doesn't make you
happier. Maybe we're focused on the wrong
thing. We want to be happier and we
believe that this next model of car wing or instrument will do
it for us. It will make us happier and more
fulfilled. No, it will just create the
spike of endorphins and dopamine that will get it, and then we'll
come back to being as miserable as we were before.
Can can we please solely blame this on Doom?
Scrolling on our phones. Yes, King, I think that is the
only evil eye in this. Whole it's a massive part of it
social media it's a massive part of it because comparing
ourselves to others is very human.
This came way before social media, however, Before we were
mostly comparing ourselves to. With our village, our
neighbours, our Co workers, this is where the choice of your job
and work environment so important because it will define
what you're focusing on. Naturally, you can't really
avoid it. But now with social media, we
compare ourselves to the whole world.
Not the lives they truly live, but the lives that they want us
to believe that they live. All this influences that that we
that we compare ourselves to believing.
Yes, and there are these masks. Acro maneuvers over crystal
clear blue waters and all of that.
Absolutely, I said with Park Landing it's pretty wild because
I see it a lot when I teach my pilots top landings.
Top landings are one of the most crucial skills when you want to
go beauty flying. However, top landings in the
mountains require a lot of patience.
It's not only about your skills about flying your wing, but also
about understanding that paramounts can trigger of the
mountain and they come in cycles.
So you may come perfectly into your top landing exactly how I
did 5 minutes ago and you are doing exactly the same thing.
But now you just got lifted by thermal and fighting it makes no
sense. So just fly away and try again.
And very often in the real big mountains, it can take an hour
easily to top plant if it's still early in the day and it's
completely fine. But very often, pilots come with
this image, the top landing. Should be what they saw.
On the 10 second reel that you just come or perfectly on the
speed bar into the slope and you land perfectly.
Everything is just super smooth and super perfect.
And they imagine that this is how it works.
But real life doesn't work like this, even for the top pilots.
They show on their reels the best moments of the best
landings, let's say. So just something to to keep in
mind what we see out there isn't real or it's a part of reality,
the pinnacle, the very top of reality.
And This is why also sharing a little mishaps and various other
aspects. It's so important.
But again, it doesn't sell so well within within 10 seconds
real. So it doesn't get as many views,
doesn't create as much frenzy. So maybe even if someone wants
to share it, maybe you won't even see it.
So just. Something to remember and it's.
Yeah, that's just cliche, but something to remember that
social media, it's not reality, it's just a tiny best of the
best moments of reality. Yeah, I think as a creator, this
is a paradox that everybody fights.
Do I go in for views or do I go in for creating unfiltered value
with my audience? But the point is this can
totally resonate to any business, which is do I go in
for community or do I go in for just profiteering.
And I think doing your own part is, is this is the answer here
that all I of course have to sustain myself in a capitalist
society, which there are some rules that I have to stick by.
But at least I'm doing my own part in trying to keep it as
clean or as real or as honest as possible.
And then like, let the algorithms do whatever, let the
universe do whatever it takes, but at least your own conscience
is is allowing you to go ahead and sleep with a peaceful mind
because you put out reality rather than just a 10 second.
Oh absolutely, you totally can create value and still get
views. I'm not such a social media
Titan to be honest. It's not main focus on my of my
life. But of course I appreciate that.
I went for the school adventure and this beautiful footage.
Why not share it with the world? It's a little.
Different if you try to be a full time creator and your
livelihood is dependent on views.
So I guess it's really again depends what do you want.
From it, I just always wanted to share a bit of what all this
flying is about and how pretty it is.
Sometimes when I like to record my flying, especially when you
do something intense, you're so focused on not to putting
yourself in some blue side on the gorge and bombing out in the
middle of nowhere, but that you don't really, you don't really
look around as much as you could.
Then you look at the footage and you're like, wow, that's
absolutely gorgeous what we do out there.
Sometimes you have all the time, you're nice and high and you
have all the time to admire the views, but sometimes it gets
pretty intense and then you look at this, look at this glacier,
look at this place. One reason to record it for me
is to be able to come back to it not only now, but also when I'm
old and crippled and I can't fly anymore.
I lived a good life like this, Beautiful places, but then also
being able to share it with people.
Collecting bragging rights for life with all the GoPro and
Insta 360 footages that you're making.
Collecting. Memories.
To come back to yeah. But I think for any aspiring
creator listening this, let me just point out that your fellow
Kiwi pilot Benjamin Carrott was kind enough to come on the show
as well a couple of episodes before, and he happened to share
a reserve through in the most raw manner possible.
I was just amazed by the honesty that he had.
He was like, all right, 365 days, my life looks like that.
But then here is one day which I'm not going to hide.
And people did respond very well to it and they were pretty happy
with whatever. Yes.
Yes, Ben is a pilot who is not only a very good pilot, has been
chasing, it's pretty hard and has a massive passion for
flying, but also he found this beautiful niche of truly talking
and and talking things through. When he flies, most of his
followers are not even pilots. They're just people on the
Internet who find it fascinating that he can fly from mountain to
mountain. And you may think a lot of us do
it. Yeah, but not a lot of us show
it to the world in such a unique way and perspective.
So it's pretty cool to see. And I think he's following us
and and his success on the social media platforms, I know
how much work and time he puts into it.
So it's totally deserved. It's amazing to see that it's
happening for him. Yeah.
There's one saying that we have a paragliding Atlas.
So stay tuned, stay excited because the magic is just
getting started. So I think that applies here.
Kinga, before we close anyone flight that you feel like
sharing that has stayed with you in past 4000 hours, let me
repeat that to my audience 4000. Hours of airtime and.
That is fascinating to hear, but if there's anyone flight that
you can share the experience, we'll be very thankful.
As you can imagine, I have dozens of flies that emotionally
touched me or feel unforgettable and they were very special.
But there were also milestones that you remember after years
that changed something. My first terminal obviously was
something deeply emotional that killed my heart and and changed
life. My first first time I did took
the Mont Blanc was a very special flight because I went to
Shamani again my still my first year of flying, still dealing
with a lot of anxiety and decision making, questioning
myself all the time. I went to Shamani.
It was a very good day, very heat wave and and there was a
lot of pilots who wanted to try, but then it was still possible
to top land on Mont Blanc. So I wanted to fly in the
massive. I didn't even think about it
because I thought it's beyond my capacity at this point.
So I wanted to fly a triangle to Aniseed that someone showed me
once and I wanted to do it. But then I met a friend of mine.
Oliver, by the way. Came here just this month to New
Zealand to fly and I this time showed him around my playground,
which was pretty special after 10 years for the special closing
circle. He's been flying there for many
years and Shamani and, and he asked me what they want to do.
I want to say to. ANSI.
I was like. That's the day to go into the
masses go into the mountains. So off I went and I went toward
the masses. To make Long story short, I did
told them all blank in the anti clockwise direction.
No one does it like this. When I landed back in the valet,
I was just like I didn't even know what happened and they
never asked me what did you do? I was like, I think I did told
them all blank but to the left I was like impossible.
No one doesn't. Think this.
I was like, I guess I did. And in particular, because I did
it this way, there's on the way, there's called MIAs, which which
is pretty high Alpine pass that takes you to the Italian side.
If you do it in a normal way, like every other reasonable
pilot, you're not on the follow the sun and it's more kind of
natural flow. But also you get to the MIAs
glacier and and the called MIAs. So the very high Alpine
committing terrain in the afternoon when days already well
developed and you understand the quality of the day, you only
commit if it's truly great. I did the other way around so I
just sneaked over the colon miast and.
Using just a little bit. Of convergence, just waving like
crazy people sitting on the past.
There's a refugee there. And then I just slide it into
the other side and then saw the glacier that you're not crossing
like in some other situation, but you're going along it.
And I look back, the path was already above me because I sank
a little bit. I was like, now let's put the
sit in the upward position. The jokes are over.
Now we're getting serious. Very carefully with the full
focus. I flew around the whole massive
and it was the first time that I flew over the terrain that could
be potentially dangerous terrain.
And the first time they connected to the fact that it's
not only that we can fly along the valleys and the green
pastures below, but also we can fly this piece of cloth over
terrain that would be impossible or very difficult to access
otherwise. And flying above glaciers until
now, it's one of them my biggest joys and and biggest privileges
in in flying. This is one of the.
Things that that. Cloud surfing and flying above
glaciers. So it's basically two things
that I absolutely love about flying.
So that real open expanded my horizontal about flying and
opened my eyes to what this piece of cloth can do, that you
can actually fly so much more interesting terrain that I
thought until this point. And there was also another
flight that that changed something dramatically in May
when I came to New Zealand. I only flew in Europe at this
point, and China and Australia. But this is basically flatland
flying over dusty paddocks. Sorry for all the Aussies
listening but because there's no real montage there.
It's not exactly. My type of flying.
I know that there's amazing distance potentials flying in
the in desert and some really cool coastal sewing.
I'm gravitating naturally toward the montage.
This is my environment and the higher the better, the Wilder
the better. I really didn't have an
experience at this point when I came first to New Zealand with
the wild montage. When I went for my first flight
in New Zealand, I saw this vast montage in front of me without
any roads, houses, cows, power, lies, anything.
No, no civilization, size. It really scared me in a weird
way, but also triggered something deep in my heart.
From the very first moment I thought it would be so amazing
to get to the point when I can travel through this mountains
alone, self-sufficient and without fear.
And it was 10 years ago. Times have changed, the sport
here really developed, but back then no one was really doing it.
No one was really flying the country, everybody were more or
less following the road. There was some 2 pilots, Brian
Moore and Nickname and none of them flies anymore.
They both had serious accidents, which is the dark side of our
sport, but then no one really did it, so it really felt even.
More remote, more. Wild and more committing and it
took me two years, but yeah, two years later I went for my first
big Vol divac estimation. I went solo through the
mountains for 16 days, but just about two weeks.
That was one of those deeply life changing experiences
because anything that I I had to process, anything that I had to
hear from my inner voice, I had enough time to hear it.
I felt very vulnerable out there because it still scared me
actually on the third day, because on the first day I got
lost. On the second day I flew some
heroic 20 kilometers, put myself on the list side and got
completely freaked out. But on the third day, after a
lot of processing and crying and an emotional journey, I flew a
stunning 180 kilometer line deep through the sudden Alps.
And it was something that I dreamt about.
I looked at this line and I thought about it, but I never
really thought seriously that it would happen.
And I put myself out there deep until now.
It makes emotional actually, because I remember who I was
when I was planning this journey, when I was going for
this adventure, and also remember what it made me and who
I was when I came out and what as a result I am right now.
And how I fly this small place now, how I treat it as my
playground. And I feel like I'm not coming
back for dinner tonight and I just on purpose put myself
somewhere deep and then spend the next day or two getting out.
I have a completely different approach to flying and to
mountains in general. But of course, this is again
thousands hours later. Back then it was the flight, the
central 83 kilometres, the second overall longest flight
after Knicks national record in New Zealand.
I didn't see Seoul. No one was fine.
But contrary to this extent, it took everything I had,
everything I was as a pilot, all the skills, all the mindset, all
the focus, all the commitment that I had.
And after those 16 days in the month is when I finally got out.
I lost almost 5 kilograms and was pretty exhausted altogether.
But I came out as a completely different human.
Not only different pilot, different human.
So in various ways, yeah, it was life changing.
And until now it's one of my most cherished flights and most
special and it's absolutely stunning.
So there's a YouTube video that's called A Girl Gone Wild,
which is basically a vlog of this journey and some of the
images also from this flight and the whole aspect of being in the
Montes alone for so long. So it was.
Quite a promotional journey, this one and particular.
This flight will always stay with me.
So it always tells me that at the end, kilometres are just
numbers and what truly stays with you are all the emotions.
And when you push and dream about something big and make it
happen and grasp it and commit to it and don't hold back, and
then truly find your flow and fly to the maximum of your
capacity and touch who you are and what you're capable of.
So this is what flying can do to us.
And so when it happens, it's always your magic.
Golden words, king, are golden words.
It's just music listening to you speak your heart.
Out It's about who you are, what you are, where you come from,
what's maybe holding your back, and what drives you.
I think we. All should give ourselves this
privilege of being alone with our mind.
And doesn't have to be the weeks.
Not everyone has this luxury or commitment to do it.
But a few hours a day, weekend and some time to reset.
Not by scrolling, not even by reading and relaxing.
Just reset with your mind and really check on ourselves what's
what do we want and what's important.
Who we are and where we are going.
But usually the most interesting things happen on the edge of our
comfort and where we are uncomfortable.
Especially this one aspect of it about safety.
If the conditions make us uncomfortable and it's really
turbulent, windy, or whatever, that's one thing of looking at
it. This is not a safety aspect.
If it's an aspect of commitment or discomfort, it's not that I
don't want to go there because it's dangerous and it's the
universe. It really sounds Kisha and I'm
not the first person saying it. It's just some deep truth in it.
And this is also why this particular flight was so
important and this particular journey was so important because
it pushed me so far outside of my comfort zone.
Since then I've been the flying way more, committing flights
were deeper with it with in worse conditions.
I've been alone in some wild mountains and I never cried
again, He said he should make sense.
It never taps to me to this point.
Once I came about on the other end of this journey, something
just ticked and it was very emotional but also very
empowering. Sometimes the flights are not
about kilometers or winning and the shrink or not even
necessarily about the best conditions.
Sometimes are the flights that that are the ones that that push
us the most and make us go for journeys.
No. Indeed, and I think the only bad
thing about this podcast is that it has to come to an end at some
point. You're going to post it way
past. I think you will need to cut it.
You'll have to cut it out or make it into two episodes
because we are almost getting to 2 1/2 hours when I start talking
about flying. It's hard to stop.
Whatever hasn't been said, we can always do it again sometime
in the future and talk about some other aspects we didn't
address this time. Indeed.
And and there's no way 1-2 podcast podcast episodes can do
justice to the amount of wealth of knowledge that you have and
the willingness to share that you have.
Most importantly. Let me point that out.
And on that note, I would also like to say that as somebody
who's seeking guidance, we might go out and chase instructors who
have a lot of experience, but we often forget about chasing
instructors who will have the willingness to share.
So from what I see that you have one of the most willing
personalities out there to share your knowledge with others.
So for anybody out there who's looking to level up their
flying, head out to Kinga's website, the link to will which
be in the show notes below. And all the awesomeness that you
heard here in the show will be there live and exclusive in
person for you if you wanted in your life.
Thank you. Thank you.
For this promotion, I mean, that's very kind.
Just trying to bring out the brutal honesty and make the
community a better place for everyone, not just for.
Us at the end. As much as it's a solitary sport
and I'm a bit of a. Loner when it comes to.
Flying. I like to fly alone.
There's particular magic about sharing knowledge and what you
learned on the way because. I learned so much.
From other pilots on the way, it's only his rights to, if you
have something to give back, to give it back to the community to
keep us all safer and happier. It's in our own interest to have
happy and healthy and big community of pilots who share
the same passion. Paragliding is still such a
young and niche sport and the thing that we can do to make it
safer and more satisfying for pilots, we should do it, I
think. It's our moral.
Duty to do it. I'm so glad I'm doing my own bit
with the show and you are. Absolutely.
And you are doing, you're doing amazing job also sharing this
talk about flying and talking about all the suspects of flying
with various experienced pilots. So yeah, we all do a little bit,
yeah. On that note, Kinga, it's been
an absolute blessing and an honored view.
And until next time, cannot wait.
Thank you so much for having and having me.
Thank you so much for having me and in there and fly high.
Stay safe everybody. Yeah.